my name is Jennifer Doudna I'm a
professor at the University of
California Berkeley and a Howard Hughes
Medical Institute investigator
my research involves studying how
bacteria fight viral infection and in
the course of that work which was a
project to discover fundamentally an
aspect of science that nobody had
investigated previously we found out
that a protein called cast 9 which is
part of the CRISPR bacterial immune
system is an enzyme that can find and
cut DNA sequences in cells it's a
molecule shown in this model in the
white part of the model that holds on to
double-stranded DNA and makes a cut just
like a pair of scissors and it can be
programmed by bacteria or by scientists
to find a particular DNA sequence and
make a break and that's important
because when that occurs in an animal or
plant cell the cell will repair the DNA
and in the process make a change to the
DNA sequence and this has been the
advent of a very exciting technology for
genome editing a way that we can alter
DNA in cells precisely and simply using
this tool in ways that in the future are
likely to lead to cures for genetic
diseases as well as lots of new insights
into the fundamental aspects of genetics
in biology
crisper bass gene-editing gives
scientists a tool for manipulating the
DNA in cells that's unprecedented we can
now understand the fundamental genetics
of any organism at a level that
previously was impossible really even to
imagine lots of people think about the
use of CRISPR and similar technologies
to cure genetic disease in humans I
think one of the exciting profound
advances that will happen in the future
actually has to do with understanding
plants and figuring out how how plants
live in their environment why plants
have the traits that they do plant
genomes are typically much much larger
than the human genome and with the
CRISPR tools we now can manipulate plant
genomes to understand the content of
that DNA and how the traits in plants
are encoded in DNA and can be
manipulated now in the laboratory using
this kind of technology so I think we're
going to see a revolution in
understanding our natural world by the
use of CRISPR based genome editing